well folks I guess this is it this will
be wrapping up my revisited ah crap I've
got fantastic beasts after this Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows Part dear
so this is going to wrap up the primary
series of Harry Potter the ones that are
actually adapted from original source
material as opposed to the fantastic
beasts which are basically direct film
creations so this one is the difficult
one to assess in a lot of ways because
if you try and look at it as a film in
isolation as a completely self-contained
thing unto itself it is pretty good it's
decent but that's really shortchange you
because it's not a self-contained thing
unto itself it is the culmination of the
seven films that came before it and
judging it on that merit it's pretty
successful I the word that kept coming
to my mind as I was watching this thing
was cathartic this has basically almost
all the moments that you would want to
have if you're gonna be wrapping this
thing up and we're seeing these
characters for ostensibly the last time
it gave the notes that you would want to
see nailed the moments that you would
want it to nail and I'm not gonna give a
spoiler warning this has been a revisit
these are movies that have been out for
a while so like you should know the deal
but things like Neville killing Nagini
that was wonderfully cathartic or Molly
Weasley taking down Bellatrix Lestrange
did Oh whoo right there that was awesome
hey the bridge blowing up set by Seamus
and Neville running away from that devil
gets some really good moments in that
and this thing and it should love it and
there's just a lot of really powerful
like even even smaller moments not even
just big action moments but you're
Maggie Smith McGonigle you
summoning the statues and they're
marching past her and she just gets this
little giddy moment of I've always
wanted to use that spell oh that's
awesome
and there's so many little moments like
that sprinkled across this thing in
small moments and in big ones and that
for me is what makes this so enjoyable
and it's not just stuff that's paying
off or giving moments for characters
that we've seen this whole time there
are things completely unique to this
film that we're seeing for the first
time that are great little touches one
of my favorite moments in honestly the
entire franchise is that dragon breaking
out of Gringotts and it gets into the
sunlight and it stops it stops because
it's so pale you can tell looking at it
that if it ever saw sunlight it has been
who knows how long and it just stops in
the Sun they actually have to basically
spur it effectively to get it moving
again but that moment of just letting
the thing have its moment in the Sun
literally I love that I'm glad the movie
took a second to slow down and give us
that I love it and oh I mean the stuff
that's been good throughout the series
throughout the franchise at this point
continues to be good all the actors
nailed these parts they know what
they're doing they're really really good
at it
Daniel Radcliffe honestly I think gives
some of his best work here I think
Daniel Radcliffe as an actor especially
at this point he is very good at
conveying thought and conveying
emotional engagement because I think his
best moments are not lines of dialogue
he delivers his dialogue well also but I
think his moments confronting Snape a
Snape is dying or talking with
Dumbledore on the heavenly Kings Cross
or just seeing his loved ones around him
before he drops the resurrection stone
so much of what he conveys in those
moments has not
thing to do with lines and it's all in
his face and he does a wonderful job
conveying a lot for a character who is
going through a lot it is really really
good stuff there are some little things
here and there some little hiccups that
I'm not I don't know how much to hold
the the film to task for so like Rowena
Ravenclaw's diadem and are the ghosts of
her daughter
you know the Grey Lady it's not like
it's out of place but it is a little bit
jarring because we really haven't seen
ghosts being around in God I mean the
last time I can remember it being
permanent it all was the fourth film we
got a little bit of Moaning Myrtle
that's been about it since then and I
and she herself had never been
established in the previous films now
like I said I don't know how I don't
know if I want to take the films to task
for that because I suspect that had they
known at the time they were filming the
earlier films had they known at an
earlier point that she was going to come
back and be important that they would
have established her earlier than they
did so I'm not sure it's necessarily the
filmmakers fault that things like that
are the case in a few instances that
being the most prominent one that comes
to my mind but when you're looking at
the thing as a whole as a finished piece
of work even if I set aside the fact
that they didn't know the end when they
started making these films looking and
removing that behind the scenes context
of the process of the medium and just
looking at as a narrative unto herself
yeah she should have been established
earlier in the series and she just
wasn't so that that stands as a flaw and
it is a flaw that sort of and things
like that
things sort of coming up or paying off
for things that are introduced fresh
that
to be callbacks but aren't really
because the things that they were
calling back to were earlier in the
books but not earlier in the film series
stuff like that becomes more of an issue
the longer these films have been out
like at the time seeing this in the
theater wasn't a huge deal because I've
been watching it being released as it
goes but things like that become bigger
issues as the things become this this
complete experience that you can binge
through and notice that kind of came out
of nowhere so there's little things like
that if I have like a major complaint
it's not even like it's not major by my
standards because by my standards a
major complaint is like a narrative
breakdown it's a it's a you know massive
character flub it's it's something at
the story structure level and this isn't
this is strictly a visual visualization
but I really feel like they drop the
ball and it's kind of a crucial moment
and that is Voldemort's death now as I
mentioned Neville getting Nagini super
love it but oh god Neville so good in
this one but the whole thing of what is
supposed to be happening of Harry and
Dumbledore you know with with their
wands you know back and you know sort of
going back and forth and the spell sort
of goes back at Voldemort and he loses
the Elder Wand the way it's visually
done it does not do a very good job of
conveying that that Voldemort spell
actually came back and hit him it just
looks like it got back to the one and
then fizzled it doesn't really look like
it hit him and then it looks like he
just kind of fades and falls apart which
it's it's a kind of a weak
visually realized death for him which is
unfortunate and a little frustrating
because I
I think it's overall it's been well
built up to but something about the
visualization of that moment doesn't
quite work it's not a complete failure
at least I don't think it is but it
should have been clearer what was going
on and it instead it kind of lands us up
oh okay so I guess guess that's it then
but overall I really do enjoy this one
this one this one more than any of the
film in the series just thunders through
on momentum because the vast majority of
the runtime is the battle at Hogwarts
and despite that even as the battle is
raging on it's able to take slower
moments intermittently because of the
way you know the assault backs off for a
little bit we have the stuff with Snape
you know there the film is able to find
a way without feeling like it's
forgotten there's a battle going on give
us quiet or slower moments so it's not
just bombastic all the way through but
this thing has the strongest and most
propellant forward momentum of any of
the films in the franchise and it is
closer to a rollercoaster sort of a film
than any of the rest of them have been
that doesn't necessarily make it better
but it does mean that because it's just
powering through and giving me all these
moments that I find very rewarding as a
viewer it's hard for me to take a lot of
issue I think this is an odd thing I'm
not sure if I've ever mentioned it
before I think in general unless
something happens you were completely
you loses you I think it's often times
easier to forgive a faster paced film
its flaws because it moves past them so
quickly
where's when something is a slower more
deliberate pace if something isn't
working you have more time to dwell on
it
whereas if it if the thing is just
barreling forward you know oh that could
wait something new and I feel like this
kind of has it has that going for it a
bit whereas other films in the franchise
if something's not quite working it's
usually going to
I lingered on and drawn-out for a little
bit longer now again that doesn't
inherently actually make this a better
film but it does make it one that I have
a lot fewer notes on just because they
don't feel like they matter as much in
this one so take that for whatever it's
worth Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part two I found it to be a very
rewarding completion for the original
series have you rewashed it lately what
do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it stuff
to do down there as well you can support
me on patreon hope this thing going
failing that or even if you also do that
you can an addition like subscribe share
this leave comments all that stuff helps
me out in some way and I appreciate all
of it so those are some options go forth
and do those things or don't you don't
have to because end of the day you're
the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]